d'accord ok doigts voilà ça bonjour ça
va moi ça va bien regarder la caméra un
mètre à m listant de sécurité attention
attention je vais faire la blague que
tout le monde rêve de faire ok vous avez
des autorisations de circulation
ok d'accord dès confiné on est prêt à
troyes 1 2 3 d'un conte filet
[Musique]
salut à tous cette émission s'adresse
une fois de plus aux personnes détenues
au personnel pénitentiaire mais
également à tous ceux qui sont confinés
dans leurs maisons dans leur appartement
on pense à vous tous derrière les murs
[Applaudissements]
au sommaire l'immense émotion d'un ténor
du barreau souhaite des cours de cuisine
d'un chef deux étoiles d'arachide ça
fonctionne le cours de sport d'une
quadruples championnes du monde
le conseil de lecture du seul député
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale qui
soit passé par la case prison selon remy
j et puis l'auteur de bd le plus lu dans
les murs merci c'est un honneur
alors la semaine dernière nous étions
que le directeur de la santé aujourd'hui
nous partons à grenoble où je vais
joindre la directrice du centre
pénitentiaire il s'appelle valérie
moussaïev bonjour valérie bonjour vous
allez bien oui on essaye
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes la directrice du centre
pénitentiaire de grenoble cette prison
elle a été créée en 1972
est ce que c'est juste de dire que votre
prison elle est vétuste
alors effectivement cette prison a
ouvert ses portes en 1972 elle a donc
d'ailleurs bientôt 50 ans puisque on
fêtera son cinquantenaire en 2022
de grands travaux de rénovation ont pu
déjà être engagée pour essayer de la
remettre du jour met évidemment en 50
ans d'utilisation intensive avec de la
surpopulation avec de faire une
utilisation continue
les locaux sont évidemment dégradé
c'est parce que vous aimeriez qu'elle
soit en tout cas vous aimeriez que ce
soit mieux
tout le monde aimerait que ce soit mieux
les personnels comme les détenus comme
j'imagine tous ceux qui nous gouvernent
évidemment vous étiez à combien de
surpopulation pour vous donner un
exemple l'année dernière en mars
2010neuf nous étions à 100 soit 163 % de
sa population avec à peu près 350 346 7
mai exactement au niveau du quartier
maison d'arrêt cette année à l'heure où
je vous parle nous n'avons pu que 283
détenus au niveau de la maison d'arrêt
et donc nous sommes à 133 % de sa
population ce qui fait une baisse de 30%
qui d'ailleurs a été a été le fait de
ces trois dernières semaines de
confinement la plus grande partie est du
coup les cellules je crois j'ai le
chiffrage v2 en préparant cette
interview je l' ai découvert une cellule
c'est 8,77 mètres carrés on y tient à
deux ou trois chez vous à grenoble non
sur grenoble on a pas ou n'a pas de
cellule à trois c'est à dire toutes les
cellules ont été doublés un lit a été
mis supplémentaires dans toutes les
cellules annie superposent et donc la
capacité d'une cellule c1 où ses deux
pouces et bâle iii d'accord très bien on
échappe en écharpe troisième dites-moi
quand vous entendez l'annnonce de cette
épidémie qui arrive quel est votre
première réaction à quoi est ce que vous
pensez d'abord il faudra vraiment que
l'incarcération normalement c'est
vraiment c'est contrebalancé par des
dispositifs qui sont mis en place comme
l'enseignement comme la formation
professionnelle les ateliers et puis
l'arrivée aussi d'intervenants de
l'extérieur c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas
seul à gérer la population pénale on a
pas mal de dispositifs qui permettent
d'être des leviers de gestion de la
détention
et là on s'est dit tout
coût et les parloirs font partie ces
leviers de gestion évidemment très
important et on s'est dit qu'il va
falloir composer sans il va falloir
gérer une détention est arrivé à trouver
un équilibre avec simplement la cellule
et la promenade ce qui était totalement
inédit
du coup qu'est ce que ce qu'est ce que
vous avez changé dans l'organisation
meilleur pragmatique en quoi ça a changé
dans la prison dès le départ on a
agrandi les promenades c'est à dire que
de deux heures au quotidien pour les
personnes détenues on est passé à quatre
heures par jour
oui une heure le matin 3 heures l'après
midi on a dû assouplir certaines règles
de descente en cours de promenade c'est
à dire qu'on a autorisé les savons les
livres les choses société on arrive vers
les douches alors que bon on n'est pas
encore en été voilà on a mis en place
deux excusés moi ça veut dire quoi ré
ouvrir les douches alors qu'on n'est pas
encore en été c'est à dire que l'été en
ouvre des douches sur les cours de
promenade de manière à ce que les
personnes âgées puissent avoir accès à
des douches
là on les a ouverts en avance puisque on
était simplement mois de mars
la problématique que vous avez valérie
blessés hier c'est que les douches comme
les promenades ces collectifs et donc là
il faut tenir les distances de sécurité
en fait oui absolument alors en
promenade c'est pour ça qu'il ya des
descentes leur ya déjà by lisation à les
cabines téléphoniques qui sont en
promenade
et c'est pour ça que les détenus ont eu
l'autorisation de descendre avec avec du
savon c'est pour ça que des affichages
et qu'on est très très dans la
communication envers les personnes
détenues sur les gestes barrières
qu'est-ce que je suis un peu curieuse
qu'est ce que je vois derrière vous
c'est une carte ign qu'est ce que ça
vous nous montrez oui c'est ça alors je
ne sais pas si vous voyez bien
alors oui alors c'est une carte du
massif du mont blanc qui est un vrai
coup de coeur me concernant puisque
depuis dans fait l'ascension du sommet
en 2013
j'ai également eu l'occasion de faire le
tour le tmb 1 le tour du mont blanc sous
tente
voilà on voit que le tour du massif de
ce fabuleux massif avec encore de très
beaux glaciers il ya une vraie
similitudes entre la montagne à mon sens
et la détention
voilà savoir que la détention comme une
aventure montanes s'est c'est être
confronté à des épreuves c'est devoir se
surpasser soi même ses devoirs choisir
peut-être un compagnon de cordée
c'est être dans des difficultés pour
aller au sommet mais je dirais qu'à
chaque fois l'aventuré unique le chemin
de la liberté 20 sommet est unique mais
maintenant on en ressort souvent plus
fort et grandit c'est un peu le sens des
missions d pénitentiaire aujourd'hui un
kiki sens prêt des détenus qui ne les
ont pas abandonnés qui sont présents et
qui les accompagne tout doucement vers
ce sommet là on s'essouffle
on s'essouffle
[Musique]
hu
arrivant au bond à monter la montagne
mais juste pour te trouves le sommet
mais tu trouves tu vois quoi c'est comme
ça puis à chaque fois tu fais des trucs
moi c'est ce à quoi s'est
puisque sommet tu trouve toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine c'est un amoureux des mots
qui va nous dire ce détenu compte rendu
de lecture par stéphane de groodt
bonjour je m'appelle stéphane de groodt
je suis comédien juge belge
j'écris des livres aussi enfin des
chroniques un peu surréaliste et je suis
je suis très heureux de pouvoir
m'adresser à vous et de vous lire l'avis
d'une détenue d'un bouquin quel élu qui
s'appelle le le collier rouge de jean
christophe rufin qui est un magnifique
auteur qui était ambassadeur qui est
médecin
je vais mettre mes lunettes parce que
sinon je vais pas grand chose et ça va
être compliqué pour tout le monde je
bloque depuis plusieurs jours sur cet
avis personnel j'ai reçu le compte rendu
de mon procès pendant la lecture de ce
livre et j'ai eu très peur peur de lire
le chapitre 10 peur de la décision de
lantier mortlake va-t-il être condamnés
à l'exil
lanthier batik détruire trois vies pour
mon cas la justice a fait de moi un
monstre une alcoolique violente sans
remords ni regrets c'est très dur à
admettre
j'étais comme mortlake blessés et
orgueilleuse mais il faut accepter et
payer ses erreurs alors j'ai dû la suite
et l'entier alléger mon coeur et qu'elle
même et angoisse morlaàs qui libre
lanthier et bon bienveillant et justice
peut-être bienveillante
je dois garder espoir et avancer or j'ai
ma fierté dans ma poche pour moi l'amour
n'est plus et n'a jamais été c'était un
leurre vous l'acceptez je dois
maintenant redresser la tête et revoir
la baisse cet excès d'idéalisme
sentimentale qui me mène qu'à la
destruction la justice mans
donnera-t-elle la possibilité maintenant
que les blessures se referme sera telle
lettre bienveillante comme lanthier mon
égard le chemin est long et le temps si
court
je me suis détruite des mes parents se
meurt de chagrin et de vieillesse et je
ne peux m'en prendre qu'à moi même
c'est très difficile à accepter à
surmonter mais j'avance et me bats et ce
livre m'a encouragé à continuer un jour
de plus parce qu'il ya toujours l'espoir
d'un travail la loyauté la persévérance
mon guillaume à moi c'est mon meilleur
ami qui n'hésite pas à me dire mes
quatre vérités
il est sain honnête et droit il est pour
moi une aide précieuse
emma mais face à mes défauts et mes
qualités aussi ce qui est agréable et
rassurant pour reprendre confiance en
soi
allez tout n'est pas noir avançons et
tirons les leçons de ses échecs
il était temps
[Applaudissements]
qui est celui qui dans le prétoire
plaide à charge ou à décharge et vient
aujourd'hui nous parler de vous des
personnes détenues et du régime carcéral
qui est la robe noire du jour bonjour
maître henri leclerc
bonjour comment allez vous bah écoutez
je vais bien comment se passe le
confinement
je suis chez moi tranquille je vois bien
alors délibérations ont déjà eu lieu il
y en à 6226 non 6266 personnes ont
d'ores et déjà été libérés adeline hazan
la contrôleuse des prisons a demandé
est-ce que 7000 libération
supplémentaires et lieux et certains
s'inquiètent en se disant qu'il ya des
criminels qui sont dehors vouloir
répondre non non non non non non non non
on ne libère pas les crimes idra sur et
vous la justice dit bois pas des clowns
le problème c'est que ya actuellement
dix mille prisonniers en trop dans les
prisons c'est le sait le chiffre minimum
il faudrait déjà qu'il n'y ait pas de
plus de prisonniers en prison qu'il n'y
a de place et donc il faut libérer plus
son corps six mille c'est pas suffisant
c'est moi je vais vu un chiffre plus
plus petits dans les journaux mais je ne
sais pas si les lélés les chiffres sont
exacts mais 6000 ce n'est pas assez il
ya 71 mille prisonniers 60000 places et
c'est surtout dans les maisons d'arrêt
que ça se passe dans les maisons d'arrêt
où il ya des gens en détention
provisoire et des gens qui ont des
courtes peines enfin on libère les gens
les gens qui sont condamnés à quelques
mois de prison pour contrefaçon et vend
par exemple des gens qui sont condamnés
pour vol je ne sais pas aa moins de six
mois de prison
ils vont de toute façon sortir et on
sortir dans deux mois dans trois mois
qu'est-ce que ça gêne de le faire sortir
maintenant est-ce qu'on va croître la
criminalité en avant sont de 2 ou 3 mois
de sortie enfin c'est une question de
sauvegarde pour les prisonniers d'abord
mais également pour les surveillants de
prison
fa je trouve que les surveillants de
prison ces deux héros aujourd'hui on
n'en parle pas de cela
1 il faut un métier qui est nécessaire
il se trouve dans une situation j'espère
qu'ils ont tous des masques et je dis
qu'actuellement
l'épidémie si l'épidémie se met à
envahir les prisons dans des conditions
dramatiques
d'après mes renseignements ce n'est pas
encore le cas mais en face des combats
ne va quand même beaucoup hein mais mais
mais mais nous aurons une responsabilité
collective effrayante
ces gens sont des êtres humains maître
leclerc par quoi devrait-on remplacer la
détention préventive dans le monde
d'après bah écoutez regardez dans un
pays comme les etats unis elle est
remplacée en général par la caution 1 et
est bon c'est une première chose
la caution c'est à dire quelqu'un qui
garanti etc
il ya des mesures comme le co le
bracelet électronique et puis surtout
pourquoi croire que tous les gens qui
sont accusés d'un acte vont fuir la
justice savait la cavale comme on dit
c'est pas si facile que ça un vivre
vivre en cavale
la plupart des prisonniers d'aujourd'hui
seraient incapables de vivre en cavale
pois chiches pour vivre en cavale donc
il est évident que la suppression de la
détention provisoire ou du moins sa
réduction drastique parce que je ne veux
pas nous être non plus lundi rêveur qui
réclament des choses dont je sais que je
n'obtiendrais pas par contre je pense
que je peux obtenir qu'on réduise dans
des conditions considérable la détention
provisoire est en tout cas dans la
situation actuelle il faudrait en
profiter
au lieu d'en manger les d'errer comme
l'a fait la garde des sceaux et comme
l'acceptait le conseil d'état est ce que
vous auriez mettre un livre à nous
recommander
non je ne sais pas quoi recommandé aux
prisonniers jeu j'ai une histoire que
j'ai toujours raconté que et que je
raconte au début de ma mémoire c'est que
quand j'étais tout jeune avocat j'ai eu
la prise il y avait à l'époque créé une
une bibliothèque dans les prisons
c'était un chariot qui passait dans les
coursives leur donnait un humour et ils
m'ont choisi prépare bien sûr alors et
se livrent les aveugles deuxième tome
des misérables il m'avait dit c'est
formidable et je suis allée acheter des
bises érable chez le bouquiniste et le
dessus le directeur m'a dit monsieur
c'est inconcevable dans ce temps là
c'est inconcevable qu'on donne un livre
un prisonnier alors rien qu'en mémoire
de cette histoire je dis aux jambes est
écouté lisez ce livre formidable
merci beaucoup m merci infiniment vous
souhaite une bonne fin de confinement au
plaisir de se trouver en liberté
écoutez moi surtout je souhaite tous les
prisonniers qui tiennent le coup on est
avec eux aussi mettre j'ai l'impression
que vous êtes très émue la wii parce que
mon sens rien pour acquis a tant vécu
avec la prison penser à ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui penser à ces gens qui sont
là vous savez je ne nie pas ce qu'ils
ont fait je ne veux pas mettre en cause
même des peines qui frappe mais je dis
que la firme prison que j'ai côtoyés
l'existence professionnelle 63 ans
aujourd'hui et bien toute cette vie j'ai
vu des gens qui souffraient et je pense
à ce qu'ils souffrent aujourd'hui sa
baisse merci de partager cette émotion
avec nous maître locale merci beaucoup
il a raison maître leclerc il va falloir
muscler nos coeurs il va falloir muscler
nos têtes et il va falloir aussi musclé
nos corps après karim benzema
voici notre cours de sport avec une
femme vice-championne olympique c'était
en 2016 judokate quatre fois championne
du monde high level clarisse agbegnenou
[Applaudissements]
bonjour c'est pas le swing move tu as
fait du judo je fais championne du monde
400 m championne d'europe et vice
champion olympique de judo
je vais vous montrer quelques exercices
en ces moments difficiles ça va vous
sortir un petit peu
voilà les esprits ça va vous aider et où
ma pire en forme
allez suivez moi donc on commence par un
petit échauffement on compte jusqu'à 10
est monté de jeu on respire bien ensuite
offerte à l'enfant bien évidemment fait
son côté bras
ensuite pendant encore un petit peu et
chants étaient choqués parce qu'il va
travailler un peu les jambes pour un
faisceau encore on ramasse on ramasse
pour un max on ramasse dont la base est
là pendant un peu aussi achoppé hébrard
on a besoin vous allez voir tout à
l'heure on monte on écarte les bras et
les jambes
[Musique]
on pense gare hystérie bien sûr très
important voilà la tâche aux biens on a
encore un tout petit peu serré pour le
cardio on va faire très lui manque deux
trois quatre cinq
on fait ça deux fois après qu'on ait
fait ça deux fois travaillé respirer
pour moi un petit coup on attend deux
minutes et là des exercices vont
commencer accrochez vous donc on a eu
besoin d'un mur et là je vais faire la
chaise je t'aime bien le 12 décembre à
90 friche pas je laisse mes draps nombre
sur les côtés mais là j'ai compté
jusqu'à 20 dans la tête
après ça directement on cherche une
ligne et là on va faire des avant-bras
vert avant par les avants rails avant
dernière et on compte aussi jusqu'à 20
heures ensuite on a trois minutes de
repos je vous montre la suite
[Musique]
on a finit directement chats 2
on compte jusqu'à 10 10 secondes plus
tard six secondes à fond donc en 30
secondes jusqu'à 10
après ça pour le fait deux fois
d'affilée et dans les bien sûr dans ces
exercices
pas de repos on enchaîne tout l'exercice
à fond deux fois ensuite on prend trois
minutes vous pouvez voir vous respirez
soufflez et on enchaîne diront une deux
trois quatre
donc comment on fait 10 et après c'est
hip hop on tient dit foire qu'on compte
jusqu'à 10 en isométrique derrière ça
pendant chaînes directement je tiens à
dire que tous et merci son temps à
enchaîner deux reprises des amis tout je
les aime pas non plus inquiété par dix
vous risquez rien si on n'y arrive pas
on est fatigué on pense tout le temps
mais on enchaîne on peut faire à la fin
donc c'est là dans le deuxième la
deuxième série qu'on enchaîne n'y arrive
pas on veut faire tout simplement un jam
touax est bien ce roman j'ai directement
avec le choisir
et derrière on peut changer un petit peu
dix secondes voilà comme sont tapés dans
les gants vous avez vu en un rien de
temps
j'ai transpiré à vous de jouer on sait
que c'est très compliqué c'est difficile
ne vous laissez pas abattre
on est allé bout on est tous ensemble
bon courage et à très vite
salut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors stéphane vous moto des noms à
l'eau ah ah c'est alexis qui est là avec
ses corbières a très bien
non parce que les députés j'arrive à
l'excès parce que les députés
travaillent et réfléchissent la prison
aussi à l'assemblée nationale celui là a
une histoire très singulière et
particulière avec la prison bonjour
alexis corbière
bonjour mais tenait bien ben ça va oui
bien et vous comment ça se passe
finalement je confirme je respecte les
consignes avec mes enfants je travaille
comme me voilà je suis à la maison à
bagnolet est ce que c'est juste de dire
avec 6 corbières quand vous êtes le seul
détenu avoir fait de la prison
attention ça me rappelle une blague de
coluche vous savez pourquoi les hommes
politiques qui font des prisons l'école
parce que les colis n'ont pas y
retourner en prison ça se discute
non mais il ya attendez il ya peut-être
des hommes politiques qui finit en
prison
moi j'ai connu par contre la prison
c'est en 1995 il ya 25 ans j'étais
militant j'avais 26 ans et une juge
antiterroriste qui s'appelait laurence
le vert avait considéré à tort j'ai été
relaxé que j'étais dans des réseaux
d'organisations de soutien à des
militants basques l'inorganisation que
sap l'été a alors j'ai pas si on se suit
encore de théâtre
ça veut dire euzkadi ta askatasuna ça
veut dire le pays basque et sa liberté
est une organisation indépendantiste
basque est né dans les années 50-60 qui
a beaucoup lutté contre le franquisme et
qui après a continué à faire beaucoup
d'attentats en espagne même quand il ya
eu le retour à la démocratie comme on
dit donc vous avez été balancés puis
relaxés voilà j'aime pas le mot balancer
parce que ça file la trouille quand on
se fait arrêter par la police et dans
les films on balance mais dans la vraie
vie bat parfois on a peur on dit des
bêtises et c'est donc j'habitais
montreuil à l'époque c'était en juin
la police antiterroriste et venus
m'arrêter je préparais un concours pour
être enseignant et pendant plus d'un
mois pendant un mois j'ai été emprisonné
à fleury mérogis le temps de ce qu'on
appelle une détention provisoire parce
que la juge considère le temps que face
à un peu le point sur le dossier que je
ne pouvais pas être dehors alors que
j'étais en train de préparer mon
concours et
pour la petite histoire j'ai été
emprisonné à fleury mérogis mais le
concours pour être prof d'histoire ce
que je suis devenu après était à amiens
et les gens c'était leur aide
ouais c'est ça mon accompagner jusqu'à
amiens en deux voitures avec des types
des motards etc où j'ai pu passer
l'examen était sur trois jours la
première journée d'examen je les passais
avec des gendarmes les menottes aux
poignets ce qui crée une ambiance les
avis du jury assez assez sympathique
vous aviez à quel âge alexis j'avais 26
ans et la prison c'est assez
impressionnant parce que bon c'est et
fleury mérogis il y avait la
surpopulation carcérale qui existe
toujours c'est le problème de notre
prison je me suis la première prison
dans laquelle j'ai débarqué avec quatre
places officielles de lit on était huit
dedans je me suis arrêté en juin 95 il
veut la coupe du monde de rugby ont
regardé les matchs sur la petite télé il
faisait chaud huit personnes huit
garçons dans une chambre entassés quand
il fait chaud il ya une ambiance laissez
moi vous dire assez voilà quoi c'est
viril et en même temps beaucoup de
solidarité entre les gens et je dis pas
du tout ça par démagogie
les gens sont solidaires il ya un rythme
qui se fait en prison bon ou finalement
pas la peine de se taper la tête contre
les murs font prendre son mal en
patience on rencontre des gens
voilà un bon mois ma situation était un
peu particulière vis-à-vis de mes autres
codétenus quand j'ai expliqué ma
situation il ya une dimension politique
qui avait bon donc une forme de respect
on me laissait on ne m'embêtait pas et
puis voilà charb le dessinateur là je
montre une petite prenons le temps mais
rapprocher d'un petit peut encore bouger
plus voilà si on met les futurs profs en
prison on va être mal la rentrée
prochaine
charb et charb stéphane que tout le
monde connaît par sonar son intelligence
et aussi par la manière tragique dont il
a été assassiné charme avait fait ce
dessin nahla effet 2 et mes amis avaient
fait des cartes postales des milliers de
cartes postales qui était distribué
derrière on ne pouvez m'envoyer un petit
message égaré ma cellule j'étais je vais
vous le dire mon numéro d'écrou c'était
246 644 sdk des cats étaient bâtiment
des tâches 4 je crois je sais pas si un
détenu qui nous regardera qui est dans
cette chambre
dans cette cellule mais mais c'est là
que j'ai été le plus longtemps
bon c'est une expérience forte
évidemment après comme parlementaire
j'ai jamais visité quelques unes de
prison il faut y aller l'univers
carcéral fait partie de notre société ça
va pas être dans un angle mort est ce
que vous auriez alexis corbière une
recommandation de lecture j'en fais deux
très rapidement parce que vous m'aviez
posé la question chère maïtena 2-2 y en
a c'est luis sepúlveda c'est un écrivain
chilien est toujours vivant là je vous
montre un de ses bouquins qui s'appelle
le vieux qui lisait des romans d'amour
alors deux mots sur sepulveda c'est un
chilien
c'était un militant politique contre la
dictature en prison pendant deux ans et
demi sous pinochet il était militant
militant communiste il va être libéré
notamment parce que il y aura une
campagne aussi international qu'après il
ira vivre à madrid il écrit beaucoup de
bouquins journalistes etc
ça c'est son grand succès je suis un
clin d'oeil à luis sepúlveda parce que
j'aime beaucoup et actuellement il a
atteint du coronavirus il est malade
j'espère évidemment qu'il va s'en sortir
il a à peu près aujourd'hui 70 ans et
l'autre c'est dino buzzati or dino
buzzati c'est un italien et en avait un
je vais dire deux mots c'est plein de
petites nouvelles gagnant s'appelle quiz
aux travaux forcés
et c'est l'histoire c'est une société où
régulièrement les prisonniers une fois
une fois durant leur parcours carcéral
ils sont sortis sont présentés à la
foule et s'il arrive à convaincre la
foule du bien fondé de leur démarche ils
peuvent être libérés et chaque fois
général la foule les renvoie en prison
et il y en a un jury il est sorti les
planter dans la foulée il a une bonne
idée et il va dire quelque chose à la
foule qui valent à convaincre finalement
de le libérer mais je vais pas dire quoi
faut le dire le la nouvelle ses quizz
aux travaux forcés
c'est dans le cas de dino buzzati stan
écrivain italien lui qui est mort dans
les années 70 c'est assez sympa c'est
facile à lire
voilà vous verrez comment l'intelligence
et peut-être justement la parole peut
libérer
même quand on est en prison merci
beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à des conflits merci infiniment
au courage à ceux qui sont détenus qui
nous regardent merci infiniment on va
rester à l'assemblée nationale avec une
de vos collègues
pour un conseil de lecture
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bonjour coralie dubost je
suis député de montpellier et vice
présidente de la commission des lois je
crois que vous avez déjà eu une petite
vidéo de la présidentielle brunch il est
donc je travaille avec elle sur tout le
secteur du régalien à l'assemblée
nationale et on pense et parle souvent
de vous on pense souvent à vous et
comment est ce que on doit améliorer
notre système et faire en sorte qu'ils
nous permettent tous d'arriver à une
société plus heureuse tous ensemble
pourquoi je vous parle de société
heureuse parce que parmi les livres que
j'ai envie de partager avec vous il y en
a un qui date un peu d'ailleurs je sais
pas si ça se voit l'image mais il est
tout abîmé parce qu'il a été élu
plusieurs fois c'est un cadeau que
m'avait fait mon père en 2007 j'ai
toujours son petit mot pour que ce livre
m'apporte la sagesse et me permettent de
trouver aussi des façons philosophique
d'avoir une vie heureuse et je le
remercierai jamais assez donc de m'avoir
offert ce double traiter la vie heureuse
de sénèque et la brièveté de la vie qui
est de se dire que c'était déjà il ya
deux mille ans quelqu'un avait pensé
tout ça ça rend humble
ça rend terriblement humble de se dire
que les questions qu'on se pose
aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle était déjà
les mêmes pour pour les hommes certains
hommes de l'époque et il donne
d'excellents conseils pour arriver à
traversé toutes les épreuves de la vie
quelle qu'elle soit arrivée à être à la
fois solide humain
en empathie mais sans tomber dans le
drama jamais comment est-ce qu'on
résiste aux épreuves de la vie et
comment les transforme comment les
améliore pour pour rebondir
vraiment je vous encourage à lire ce
sera un très très bon moment pour vous
tous prenez soin de vous ok donc là je
lance va être de la semaine donc la
musique parce que les livres c'est bien
ça
oui bien sûr la lecture c'est bien donc
je ferai comme ça tu vas la lecture
c'est bien mais la musique ça compte
puisque la musique raconte évidemment
tout le monde n'importe où tout le temps
en prison ou ailleurs ça forcément et
donc à ce moment là je dis guizmo de
tryo
voilà donc je ferai comme ça guizmo de
tryo pour le live de la semaine
voilà
[Applaudissements]
salut les amis c'est guizmo du groupe
tryo écoutez je pense très fort à vous
en ce moment quand je vois déjà que nous
deux ors et ben on en chie avec le
confinement j'imagine comment ça doit
être compliqué dans les prisons voilà
j'ai une énorme pensée voilà pour vous
vraiment c'est sincère ça vient du fond
du coeur prenez soin de vous faites
attention les uns aux autres et puis
garder espoir surtout je vais vous
chanter une petite chanson d'amour voilà
parce que je me suis dit que que en ce
moment où les visites ne sont pas
tolérés dans les prisons on doit manquer
beaucoup d'amour
on doit manquer les siens ses proches sa
femme son compagnon sa compagne ses
enfants bien sûr
donc voilà au nom de tous ceux qui sont
amoureux et qui tiennent à leur couple
ne gardez pas ne gardez pas trop de
rancune envers ce virus vous allez
bientôt pouvoir revoir vos chérie chéri
chéri
parce qu'il n'ya pas que des ordres en
prison je fais aussi une dédicace à
toutes les femmes emprisonnées voilà je
vous aime tous très fort prenez soin de
vous faites attention à vous et aux
autres
cette chanson s'appelle toi et moi elle
est pour vous ce matin 3 me licencie des
embouteillages et pollution pour paris
agglomération
ce matin l'abbé pierre est mort on
l'antenne sur tf1 de clochards retrouvé
mort près du canal saint martin ce matin
le calme va de l'avant de soldats noirs
pour l'occident 10 civils deux tués à
bagdad en débat sanglant du jihad
croyez moi dans tout ça on apparaît pas
on se contente d'être là on s'aime et
puis voilà on s'aime ce matin menace de
l'épave y ait trop de fascisme en
bavière l'iran travaille au nucléaire et
à rivas quoique niger se battent un
rapport sur le climat
il ne survivrait que les rats fonte des
glaces en alaska ico chaleur en angola
toi et moi dans tout ça on apparaît pas
on se contente d'être là on s'aime et
puis voilà on s'aime
toi et moi dans le timbre au milieu de
deux enfants plus père saad plus de gens
plus de vent on s'aime
ce matin ce matin ce matin pendaison de
saddam l'eau et du gris au scandale le
10 mai se meurt sous les balles du type
qui fait ce capital toi et moi quand
tout ça on n'a pas réparé on se contente
d'être là on s'aime et puis voilà on
s'aime toi et moi dans le temps au
milieu de nos enfants plus personne plus
de gens plus de vos mains
on s'aime ce matin il fait presque
boulot ça tombe bien je me suis levé tôt
avec le coq et les oiseaux sont jaunes
aux îles sans météo ce matin ja pas
qu'un autre jour avec toi mon amour
cette journée durera toujours on ne fera
jamais
le tout toi et moi dans tout ça on
apparaît pas on se contente d'être la
11ème et puis voilà roussel toi et moi
dans le temps au milieu de nos enfants
plus personne plus de gens plus de vent
on s'aime bise à tous les frérots les
frangines prenez soin de vous à très
vite dehors
ciao bye le garçon que nous allons
rencontrer maintenant nous fait voyager
dans le temps un peu comme cette rue
décorée pour un film de cinéma qui n'a
pas pu se tenir pour cause de pandémie
et voici un décor des années 40 lui vous
le retrouvez toutes les semaines dans
votre télévision quelle que soit vos
murs pour vous parler de livres
il ne change pas d'habitude mais cette
fois ci c'est pour vous qu'il le fait
françois busnel
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous c'est françois busnel je
voudrais vous dire qu'aujourd'hui je
pense à vous particulièrement à vous en
ces temps de confinement et de
confinement sans accès au parloir
en revanche peut-être allez-vous accès à
ceux ci une bibliothèque avec des livres
n'importe quel livre dedans je vais vous
en proposer trois aujourd'hui qui me
semble pouvoir vous aider à élargir
votre horizon est peut-être à comprendre
pas mal de choses notamment la situation
actuelle le premier cette année d'un
écrivain américain qui s'appelle jim
harrison sont peut-être l'un des plus
grands écrivains d'aujourd'hui parce que
il raconte les vies cabossées et la
manière de les reconstruire
trois nouvelles assez courte les trois
nouvelles dans les jambes d'automne et
qui raconte comment des personnages
cherchent la vengeance à la place de la
justice à refaire leur vie en repartant
de zéro quand ils ont déjà pas mal fait
bêtise et pour la gay et puis comment
l'amérique s'est construite sur le
massacre des indiens sur un génocide
c'est absolument formidable et c'est
aussi un éloge des grands espaces un
autre livre d'une canadienne qui
s'appelle emilie saint-john mende est un
roman qui s'appelle stationnent heleven
il ya deux petites filles et en anglais
station heleven et ça raconte un peu ce
qu'on est en train de vivre c'est-à-dire
l'imprévu quand tout à coup une épidémie
pas de coronavirus et de grippe la
grippe de géorgie s'abat sur la
population et ravage 98 99 % de la
population c'est l'histoire d'une troupe
de survivants et le mot troupes et le
bien choisi parce qu'en réalité ces
survivants ensemble vont comprendre que
c'est en jouant les grands classiques du
théâtre et particulièrement les oeuvres
de shakespeare de manière itinérante
auprès des rares survivants dans des
endroits absolument apocalyptique
c'est en jouant shakespeare que
l'humanité peut être changé et puis on a
toujours besoin poésie je trouve la
poésie vous allez c'est pas toujours les
classiques c'est pas non plus forcément
en verre ça peut être tout simplement
des petits textes lumineux
et voici un poète que je tiens en
immense estime il s'appelle christian
bobin et vous pouvez choisir n'importe
quel livre de christian bobin
ce sont des livres toujours très court
composée de très courts chapitres une
page une page et demie deux pages qui
raconte son rapport au monde à
l'émerveillement
malgré la souffrance à la beauté malgré
la douleur à la façon dont on peut se
relever d'un deuil dont on peut se
relever d'une accusation dont on peut se
relever de la solitude
c'est absolument pas ce qu'on pourrait
appeler la littérature feelgood qui
console mais c'est une littérature très
puissante et qui quand on leur à lui
permet d'aller mieux et permet surtout
d'envisager mieux la vie voilà christian
donnera je pense à vous et je vous
souhaite bon courage et de bonne lecture
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr vous vous posez la question
pourquoi est elle un oignon dans la main
et bien pour une bonne raison parce que
nous allons retrouver thierry marx chef
deux étoiles qui croient à la deuxième
chance qui donne des cours de cuisine en
cellule
puisqu'on apprend à cuisiner en cellule
puisque une cuisine en cellule alors
pourquoi l'audience me direz vous et
bien parce que nous avons cuisiné un
oeuf mollet alors ça ne nous explique
rien
oui si un oeuf mollet mais dans une
soupe à l'oignon
cqfd bonjour thierry marx aujourd'hui un
plat à moins de trois euros et avec la
liste cantine à bhl en détention on va
préparer le deuxième place of poché et
une façon un petit peu de revisiter la
soupe à l'oignon
je vais pas éplucher l'oignon jour
fastidieux je fais le couper en
rondelles
donc j'ai continué les oignons j'ai pris
des oignons sec pas trop vieux s'ils
sont trop nous ça fonctionnera pas donc
il faut les garder un petit peu ferme
voilà je coupe juste la partie un peu
fermes et là je mets directement dans la
poêle je baisse un petit peu alors
évidemment tout ça ça a été nettoyé et
passer à l'eau avant je vais couper le
poireau dans le sens de la longueur
même chose pour la pomme de terre jean
lèques pas la peau peu de matières
grasses gros sel tout bêtement tour de
moulin à poivre
si vous avez dit que du poids bromure
détention en général on a que du poivre
moulu ça fonctionne ça y est ça commence
à colorer joliment pendant ce temps là
je vais faire bouillir l'eau c'est
presque cuit
les oignons sont quasiment confie
caramélisées un petit peu mieux je vais
ajouter une toute petite goutte de miel
ça aussi ça a été continue ce matin ça
va enlever un petit peu l'amertume du
poireau s'est joliment coloré pas
laisser cuire doucement l'eau à
ébullition
[Applaudissements]
cinq minutes et maintenant je vais
ajouter une toute petite goutte d'eau
et là on va laisser diffuser le goût
caramélisé de légumes ça va infuser ce
qui me laisse le temps de me préparer
pour le dressage
il est juste mollet juste ce qu'il faut
il est encore à température l'oignon
confie la pomme de terre caramélisées
confites avec la peau le poireau confie
toujours pareil avec l'eau et le miel
je vais garder ce petit morceau de nyon
et ce petit morceau poireau pour finir
n'oublions pas rajouter un tout petit
peu d'eau pour finir la cuisson on va
pas porter à ébullition va juste monté
au frémissement
on va poser délicatement l'oeuf mollet
le bouillon en fait c'est sympa l'oignon
dans l'esprit de la soul oignons
j'arrose bien l'oeuf pour qu'il soit à
température
olivier chez sur le savoir ça donne un
très très très très bon goût alors of
mollet façon soupe à l'oignon coup
générale 1 euros 90 avec la liste
cantine à bhl en détention bon appétit
non non non la télé gratuite en prison
là parce qu'il ya pu les parloirs mais
d'habitude elle est payante ses 14 euros
par mois bah oui tu as bien déjà pour
nous la télévision en ce moment même
pour eux oui mais non ce qu'on fait
c'est que oui c'est ça on reprend des
meilleurs mandat postroff avec des
grandes interviews et ensuite bernard
pivot nous explique il revient sur ce
souvenir
oui la crg crg notre invité le papa de
tintin quoi oui tintin le reporter tu es
un peu qu'est ce que tu as à la chaux
comprends pas
[Applaudissements]
comment vous est venue l'idée de ce
personnage au fond quelles sont les
influences qui vous ont amené à créer ce
personnage de tintin reporter de 15 ans
je crois que j'ai toujours eu envie de
raconter des histoires et je les raconte
et souvent c'est pour ne pas les oublier
les illustrer quand j'étais déjà très
très très jeune
et puis après lorsqu'on m'a confié la
rédaction de ce petit supplément
illustré que le petit vingtième parce
que d'un supplément de ce journal le 20e
siècle
j'ai donc pensé à faire une histoire
d'un petit bonhomme mais comme je savais
très mal dessinée je suis très très très
mal et que je me disais que ça allait
tout même duré quelques semaines j'ai je
me suis contenté de faire un petit rond
un cercle petite mèche pour donner un
accent comme ça j'étais certain que ce
personnage dont le reconnaîtrai de
dessin en dessin et de semaine en
semaine
c'est vrai que le premier tintin qu'on
trouve dans le pays des soviets on va
nous le montrer tout à fait différent de
tintin qui est devenu célèbre par le
croquis oui oui pourquoi alors c'est
tout bête
je pencherais plutôt pour donner un
accent pour pour qu'ils ne sont pas tout
à fait rond sinon il aurait un cercle ça
n'était pas tellement reconnaissable 6
enfin il fallait un petit accent à ça
j'ai donné les groupes et pourquoi alors
tout de suite mieux pourquoi un chien le
parce qu'il est pas beau que l'on soit
seul pour commencer afin d'écrire
voyager avec pour voyager je crois qu'un
chien est encore la meilleure animal
faisait difficilement de voyager avec
n'y avait qu'un téléphone avec un chat
ça devient difficile alors un chien
c'était la richesse des chiens à la mode
en ce moment là il y avait un journal
qui s'appelait ric et rac où c'est
nécessaire et le petit chien c'est un
espèce de fox terrier comme ça mais qui
est il de vous en tintin ou de vous de
ce que vous êtes de ce que vous auriez
aimé mais je crois que qu'il s'agisse de
romans ou qu'ils s'agissent
de théâtre mais je crois que tout auteur
quel qu'il soit y compris un auteur de
bande dessinée se met lui-même se
projette sur ses personnages et je crois
que tintin c'est une partie de moi même
qui aurait voulu être un héros qui
aurait voulu être un reporter comme vous
simplement pour commencer et puis c'est
le capitaine haddock avec mes colères
mais colère j'avoue est aussi capitaine
haddock oui je suis tout ça je crois que
vous êtes la castafiore
oui parfois parfois ça m'arrive
voyez-vous le modèle de l'opéra comique
dont un homme enfin non mais les
principaux personnages
je me retrouve en de parfois je crois
que c'est vrai je vous disions et dupont
c'est moi oui aussi rouge comme étant
qu'acheter des bêtises ça m'arrive de
chats des bêtises et alger est un grand
bienfaiteur de l'humanité
pourquoi parce que grâce à leur bande
dessinée grâce à un héros dont ils ont
eu l'idée
ils répandent dans l'eau près des
lecteurs de de la poésie de l'humour de
la drôlerie
on est pris par les histoires on est on
est subjugué par on a envie d'aller
jusqu'au bout de l'histoire et en même
temps c'est du rêve cdc c'est de la
poésie encore une fois ça fait du bien
quand on lit un arg ça fait du bien
quand on lui en astérix a fait du bien
et donc c'est pourquoi tous et des
grands dessinateurs qu'il soit le
dessinateur il et puis aussi ce qu
écrivait les textes mais je faisais tout
lui l'était l'extraordinaire je trouve
que ce sont de grands bienfaiteurs de
l'humanité je ne peux pas faire un
meilleur compliment
[Applaudissements]
je compose le numéro de jérémy l'âge
l'art qui est gérée minaj l'art il est
surveillant à la prison de grenoble et
le voilà bonjour jérémy bonjour merci
d'être avec nous alors je vois bien que
vous êtes surveillants parce que c'est
écrit sur votre tenue et je ne comprends
pas bien où vous êtes là alors je suis
en actuellement dans la salle de
musculation de grenoble par ce qui est
mon univers actuellement alors gérer
mais vous normalement vous vous occupez
du sport et vous avez remis votre
uniforme tout à fait habituellement
survêtement et jérôme l'uniforme depuis
depuis le début du continent afin de
devenir leader parce que donc évidemment
il n'y a plus de cours de sport donc
cette salle de muscu dans laquelle vous
êtes plus personne n'y viens depuis le
début du confinement exactement donc le
début de confinement sportif et du coup
je me suis le quartier mineurs mais je
garde aussi un oeil attentif sur le
corps et on essaye d'être créatif en
proposant des programmes individualisés
dicro smic quand on distribue dans les
cellules enfin palliant plat la
situation ce qui permet aux verts 1
promenade et éventuellement un cellule
oui donc tous les détenus va le cours de
sport
absolument pourquoi parce que c'est ce
qui permet au corps de se libérer parce
que c'est une sont pas à la détention et
parce que je pense que c'est
indispensable
et ce ne sont pas indispensables au bon
déroulement vous montrer à quoi elle
ressemble à la salle de fitness elle les
fenêtres convoi jérémy elle donne sur
quoi sur les cours de promenade sur les
cours de promenade et qui a fait des la
déco alors ça c'est des pros c'est un
projet qui avait été fait avec
avec des détenus et un graffeur voilà on
a mis ça en place que notre mur
commençait un peu à fatiguer donc du
coup on a mis ce projet en place et vous
verrez au gymnase à côté il ya aussi des
graphes plutôt plutôt sympa ah bon mais
nous on vous suit allez voilà le gymnase
je sais pas si le graff est visible
j'essaye de ne pas trop bouger du coup
je pense ça doit pas être simple pour
vous êtes un très bon cadre heures il
n'y a aucun problème qu'est ce qui est
écrit
champion champion's league championship
exactement il est magnifique de gymnase
oui on est plutôt fier de nous on est
plutôt fier de nous ils en prennent soin
on fait en sorte que que ça se passe
pour le mieux et voilà ça a super outil
de travail pour nous et est vraiment
tout le monde
tout le monde est content de venir dans
ces lieux généralement qu'est ce que
vous me donneriez comme qualificatif
avant qu'on se quitte pour raconter se
veut dynamique être d'y être dynamique
motivé et passionné surtout passionné
par quoi passionné par le contact humain
la communication et puis moi en plus je
pense que le sport est état est un bon
vecteur pour tout ce qui est à accomplir
ici donc voilà j'ai 3 j'y crois
fortement même dans ces moments ne
paniquez pas mais il ya un renard
derrière vous gérez millage la remercie
beaucoup
oui merci beaucoup les jérémy là je la
remercie infiniment je vais retrouver
quelqu'un que vous connaissez peut-être
en tout cas vous avez peut-être entendu
parler de son association fu jo il
s'appelle mouloud mansart et il a passé
dix ans en prison et puis il en est
sorti et dorénavant il organise la venue
de la culture en prison et en
particulier de concert merci jérémy
merci à vous voilà bonjour mouloud
bonjour vous amener la culture en prison
vous alors
moi quand j'étais quand j'étais en
détention j'ai pas eu la chance de 2 qui
fait sur un concert ou une activité
culturelle qui m'intéressait vraiment et
est vraiment ça va manquer et si on met
dernières années de prison j'ai eu la
chance de tomber sur un directeur qui
était assez ouvert et qui m'a laissé
organiser des concerts au sein même de
la prison
donc là je vous résume un parce que ça
c'est pas passer aussi facilement que je
vous raconte
mais mais du coup j'ai pu organiser six
concerts alors que j'étais détenue et
finalement quand je suis sorti je
pensais pas du tout continuer à faire ça
et puis les collègues était resté en
prison on me rappelait mon dilemme nous
députés plus là y'a plus rien essayé de
nous organiser un concert ou 2 tu vois
et puis pour la faire plaisir je leur
avais envoyé de trois artistes comme ça
et puis finalement je me suis dit que
c'était peut-être c'était peut-être bien
je continue parce que j'avais la
facilité à faciliter le faire et donc je
me suis lancé là dedans nous avons dix
ans gfr simplement à langueux et puis
finalement les berbères on a fêté en
disant oui d'actifs alors vous nous
parlez de concert c'est uniquement de la
musique c'est toujours des concerts qui
viennent en prison où il ya d'autres
choses d'autres aspects de la culture
en tout cas au début moi j'ai fait tout
ce qui touchait la culture urbaine
puisque c'est de là que je viens donc
beaucoup de concerts de rap et des
activités aussi des ateliers d'écriture
des ateliers de dj des ateliers stand up
nous sommes avant tout ce qui touchait à
l'art de la rue et puis finalement là on
a commencé à ouvrir avec des artistes
comme grand corps malade battle chedi de
cali etc je vois disque belle tm
derrière vous
et on entre en prison j'avais joey starr
sa raquette killer on a fait un sound
system la prison de nice à la demande de
l'ancien directeur denis ce qu'était
fameux thé mais peut-être joué et on a
foutu bordel et moi ce qui m'a tenu et
c'est pour ça que j'ai tenu à terme et
conserver un c'est vraiment la musique
donc c'était c'était ça qui me donner de
la force et qui me donnait envie de
revenir dans le système quoi on a sorti
un album il ya six ans qui s'appelle
achetant académie où on avait travaillé
pendant un an et demi avec un groupe de
détenus et où j'avais invité une
cinquantaine d'artistes a participé à la
belle vie mes frères du retour d'un
futur après avoir que jésus puis je
passe les portes du pénitencier avec
courage a pas de litige la promenade qui
comme la plage attention faites pas trop
de vagues
ce compact pouvoir s'acheter de la
traîne t'attend pour passer la pommade
respire
qu'est ce qui se passe quand le
confinement est au rendez vous avec
l'enfermement l'épidémie en prison vous
imaginer quoi vous vous imaginez sont en
prison dans la prison et il n'y a pas de
parloir il ya plus de liens ya plus
aucun lien social pour l'épauler pour
les confinant prison donc ça doit être
vraiment vraiment encore plus dur que
quotidien mais j'ai envie de dire c'est
encore même entraîner les gars ou
l'autre vous avez tout à fait raison les
parloirs sont fermés et du coup j'en
profite
c'est extrêmement compliqué pour et les
familles et les détenus donc nous on se
propose si vous avez un tweet un message
un dessin n'importe quoi a envoyé à
quelqu'un qui est détenu en prison vous
pouvez utiliser cette adresse
déconfinement accueillir pour en sortir
point org déconfinement à lire pour en
sortir pour orgue et du côté des détenus
si vous avez envie de partager ce que
vous êtes en train de vivre en ce moment
si vous voulez nous raconter ce qui se
passe pour vous dans cette période
incroyable de confinement dans
l'enfermement et bien créé bennoo lcp
106 rue de l'université 75007 paris
lcp la chaîne parlementaire lcp 106 rue
de l'université 75007 paris
merci beaucoup au moulleau de bonne
chance et bonne route avec votre
association et vive la culture en prison
merci
[Applaudissements]
le mot de la fin nous emmène retrouver
quelqu'un que vous connaissez tous
absolument tous puisque c'est lui qui
écrit et qui dessine la chose la plus
lue en prison berthet one dans un
instant si je trouve mon téléphone
bonjour berthet bonjour comment allez
vous ça va très bien merci beaucoup à
vous de mon avis p non mais bah vous est
incontournable vous êtes le celui que
tous les prisonniers lise c'est vous
merci c'est un honneur vous le savez ça
à ce qu'il paraît j'en ai entendu parler
le dessin vous l'avez rencontré comment
et où il ya longtemps bien avant la
prison à vous l'avez rencontré vous
étiez tout petit d'ailleurs le dessin
alors oui il faut dire faut dire que moi
je suis de la génération club dorothée
vous savez oui et tout petit donc je
regardais le club dorothée et je voyais
à cabu déçu mais j'avais 12 ans dix ans
plus tôt et je me disais que plus tard
j'aimerais dessinateurs comme lui c'est
quand même un peu par la case prison
vous êtes devenu bédéiste puisque quand
vous êtes vous avez été condamné à 10
ans de prison vous avez passé votre bac
vous avez fait des études et vous est
remis au dessin c'est là que vous êtes
sérieusement mis au dessin en prison
tout à fait disons que pendant la
période d'incarcération
j'avais du temps et j'ai donc décidé de
reprendre mes études de passer mon temps
à bon escient en fait et en reprenant
mes études eh bien j'ai aussi en même
temps repris ma passion première qui
était élevée 100 est-ce que vous avez le
la conscience d'être un modèle
alors moi ça me fait bizarre d'entendre
ça je ne sais pas mais j'espère que les
personnes détenues peuvent prendre
quelque chose s'il a quelque chose de
positif à prendre chez moi j'espère
qu'ils la trappe en plein rush est ce
que vous vous souvenez d'un livre d'une
bd ou d'un morceau de musique qui est
lié à cette période de votre vie
alors oui oui j'ai coupé le bâtiment
guen peuvent passer à l'ancienne et
alors qu'est ce que vous dessinez en ce
moment alors en ce moment je suis en
train d'écrire des pages de bd sur mon
confinement avec humour et dérision bien
sûr vous nous montrez 10g page montre ça
alors aujourd'hui j'ai raconté une
histoire en trois pages dans trois
pardon aux trois cases devine un virus
sur les virus en fait très souriant
n'est donc à voir et glenn d'un pointu
la perse un parent m'a alors oui parce
que en fait effectivement ce virus c'est
quelque chose de terrible qui fait des
morts et c est moi j'essaie de quand je
raconte des histoires de casser un peu
l'ambiance en fait avec de l'humour et
avec de la dérision de d'adoucir un
petit peu les propos alors là c'est
juste à un premier jet évidemment mais
en tout cas voilà je m'inspire de ce que
je vis au jour le jour et en ce moment
comme on en confinement
j'ai envie d'expliquer un petit peu ce
que pour les générations futures
pour ceux qui liront ça un jour qui se
dire on attendait c'est vrai que le
monde a été bloquée un moment donné
parce qu'il semble lui en fait qu'est ce
qu'on vous souhaite pour cette fin de
confinement berthet one est bien la
santé la santé puis j'espère que toutes
les personnes qui nous écoutent qui nous
voient passeront cette crise avec succès
et puis à force à toutes les personnes
qui qui ont des proches qui subissent en
fait le mauvais sort à savoir qu'ils
vivent ces mauvais moments avec les
virus
merci beaucoup verte et voilà merci
infiniment merci
voilà on va se quitter maintenant avec
un violoniste qui joue tous les jours
pour ses réseaux sociaux ils jouent
spécialement pour vous qui n'avez pas
internet ce soir renaud capuçon va nous
interpréter vive elle dit un petit mot
pour vous dire que la librairie le
square à grenoble va adresser tous les
livres dont nous avons parlé pendant
toute l'émission à la prison grenoble
bien entendu et que vous qui êtes
derrière les murs de grenoble pour élire
ses livres
merci à renaud capuçon de de nous
accompagner pour la fin on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine bien entendu d'ici
là et les rediffusions mais sinon la
semaine prochaine 19h30 sur lcp c'est ça
hein c'est lcp des comptines et où que
l'on soit dedans et dehors
salut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]